taking a broader view
what's china's
overall goal
at the moment for the nation what do
they want
well
i'll just put it in their terms i mean
what the the chinese strategic documents
have said is they're looking to have
global leadership uh by the year 2049
which is the hundredth anniversary of
the of the chinese state the
chinese revolution what's going on
what's global leadership and where did
they say this
so right now
historically
china has seen itself as the middle
kingdom it's it's certainly
a
or one maybe the great civilization of
its region and they had a relationship
with the countries around it that was
based on that understanding which is
very very different from the principles
of the post-war international order that
were established by the united states
and the uk and our allies in the
aftermath of the of the second world war
and so china would like to have that
freedom of maneuver china sees
the united states um i think as a
country that's trying to keep china down
and sees that post-war liberal
international order as something that is
just a veiled threat it's it's not
something designed for the common good
but something designed to keep others
down and as they see it keep
the united states um in the in a role of
of primacy and they want to get out of
that and part of getting out of that at
least in my view
is uh deeply undermining this system the
alliance system
that emboldens
uh countries uh like uh japan and korea
and australia to stand up to uh to china
that doesn't necessarily mean that china
wants to militarily take over the world
china says they never take over other
entities but that's just a bald-faced
lie because you just have to have it
just a different view of they give you
if if i were to say america is the whole
world
then america would never invade any
other country because i had just
declared that all other countries are
america if china just says the entire
south china sea is china
then seizing territory in the south
china sea isn't aggression it's just
this is this this is ours so they they
use the it's the big brother little
brother stop hitting yourself thing all
over again isn't it stop hitting
yourself it was something like that but
the thing is
for them um yeah i mean for them they're
just making declarations i mean that
that's why
uh for china managing the information
space is so important because the idea
is well just just declare some big crazy
thing
and then start defending that crazy
thing and then you act according to that
principle and then people will say hey
you're wrong and you say oh no no um we
we have a claim to the entire south
china sea so this is just uh just a
dispute this isn't aggression we're not
seizing territory we're not attacking
india um we're just um
part of this
of this dispute
um where we haven't uh xinjiang and and
and tibet
uh taiwan uh china has uh the the the
the government on mainland china uh has
only controlled taiwan
for
four years since 1895
and yet that claim there are lots of
other countries that have a much
stronger claim to other places that have
let bygones be bygones but again china
it asserts its reality
and then tries to defend
um the reality that it's that it's
created
what is can you explain what china is
doing in the south china sea with its
little island that's uh how it's
expanding territory yes um so um a big
vulnerability that china has is that the
united states navy
is
still more advanced and stronger and the
south china sea is one of the main
thoroughfares for trade it's
not it's natural resource risk
rich not just fishing but
oil and it's critically important
china has made this just absurd
outlandish and according to
international law illegal claim called
the nine-dash line um to essentially the
entire south china sea
and then what they did
is they claimed these
the essentially reefs in the middle of
the south china sea
seized them and have built massive
military installations uh on those
islands and what they're doing so the
united states has aircraft carrier
battle groups and if you've ever seen
them they're just unbelievably awesome
displays of power
but if you have military installations
right in the middle of the south china
sea
that's like a huge aircraft carrier in
one of the critic most important places
where you would have an aircraft carrier
and
if you have a land base you can really
do a lot and the united states could
neutralize those bases in a war scenario
i mean they're just sitting there so you
could you know attack them in a war
but all most of life and hopefully all
of life happens outside of a war of a
war scenario so it's again it's the same
thing china declares an imaginary
reality and then starts acting as if the
imaginary reality is is real
and then when people raise questions
about it attacks those those people or
those countries isn't there a rule to do
with a particular radius around the
island it's a 90 mile radius or
something so by china picking up these
little reefs they're slowly expanding
that territory because they all
intersect it's the convention of the law
of the sea and these little reefs these
little sunken
natural structures
don't have i mean one the claims are
totally illegal two
even if they were legal these reefs
don't afford that kind of protection but
they take these reefs and then they're
pouring cement and they're building
structures on
on top of them and in order to make
these these claims and and what they're
trying to do is just create
realities on the ground that will
transform the the conversation because
now they have these military
installations and and they're they're
telling every every other country
what are you gonna do about it are you
gonna are you gonna force us to leave
and china has built up its massive
military they're now investing
hugely in hypersonic weapons and nuclear
weapons in attack submarines
and so it's not even clear
that if the united states were to
challenge uh those those islands at
least at this stage and there were some
kind of military confrontation it's not
even clear who uh who would win so what
china's trying to do
is just change the realities on the
ground regardless of the
of the legalities regardless of what it
does to any concept of a rules-based
international order
and then just say well that's that's the
reality get used to it
they're [ __ ] about with anchoring
bias
and uh status quo bias and first mover
advantage better than anyone that i've
ever seen as you say by
proclaiming a particular situation and
then matching reality to that situation
and then saying what do you mean this
this huge concrete building has always
been here on this island it's always
been our territory um i mean
it's not the most subtle of strategies
but it definitely seems like it's being
effective and it's being rolled out
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace